[Music]
hello and welcome to i'd like to know
this is our bible question and answer
program the opportunity is given to us
and we covet this opportunity to
dialogue with you to answer your
questions to go into the word of god to
study from the word of god and to gain
knowledge which is meet in due season
for our thirsty souls here on this earth
as we prepare for citizenship in the
world which is to come i'm c.a murray
and i'm in a company of pastor daniel
miranda pastor it's always good to have
you here thank you pastor cia it's good
to be here too
we like this program and we say that
week in and week out because it does
give us the opportunity to hear what's
on your minds to hear what's in your
heart
and it gives us a feel for the kinds of
things
that the adventist community the
christian community is discussing the
questions that they have and the answers
that they seek so we encourage you to
send in your questions we have
an impressive list of questions the
stack is getting thicker and thicker and
we are waiting our way through them as
best we can given the constraints of
time we have talked about perhaps
extending the show to an hour i don't
know if that is going to happen but it
it is
on the docket to be discussed because
there are so many questions that are
coming in and the truth be told we don't
necessarily want to rush through your
questions we want to take our time and
give
each question due diligence we try to
take them in the order that they arrive
but there are some times when we've got
to bring more immediate issues to the
fore and sometimes uh when we get these
long homework assignments we've got
we've got to push them down down just a
little bit uh but we want to give get to
them in the order that they come and um
we want to give each one due difference
some questions you can get through with
just a line or two of answer
then there are those who who take uh
which take a little bit more time uh our
last program we dealt with a question
that really kept uh us for the entire
half hour so uh depending on the the
question we like to give it uh as much
time as we feel that it needs we will
make you this promise
that your answers will come from the
word of god
your questions rather coming from the
word of god our answers will likewise
come from the word of god and we make
you that promise we are convicted and
convinced that it is a little late in
earth's history to be
bantering about the opinions of men so
we
promise you that we'll find an answer
from the word of god if indeed an answer
can be found and give you that answer
should you like to join us should you
like to be a part of this program we
invite you to send your questions to tv
at some tv dot o-r-g that is tv
at s-u-m as in mary tv.org
and we'll put them in the stack and
we'll get to them just as soon as we
possibly can
pastor if you would please
lead us in prayer
my pleasure let's
pray dear heavenly father
what a privilege to be here in this
program
and help answer the questions of your
people
we pray that
the holy spirit who enlighten the minds
of the bible authors may also enlighten
our minds and that
we may only give an answer
in light of bible truth
in the name of jesus we pray amen amen
amen and amen
um our first question pastor comes to us
from e.m uh it simply says
it has to do with
um
holding things in common the the
practice in the early church the
question is is right up front why don't
we share our possessions in common as
the early church did now of course uh
the the writer em has a number of
supporting texts and scripture but they
all go to buttresses questions so
um perhaps we'll just deal with with the
question
why don't we share our possessions in
common as the early church did
well this is a very practical
question with a practical answer
uh and i'm glad this is not a
theological because sometimes we need
practical stuff as well
very true and
i have a simple answer to
this i think as a church
we do not have the first love that the
early apostolic church has
and that's the main reason why
we do not share our possessions in
common as the early church the early
church was a church that was on fire for
god
they had just received the early reign
at pentecost
they knew things
they had seen the fulfillment of
prophecy
they had
witnessed the sacrifice of jesus christ
now they understood what it meant
and they knew they had a mission
before jesus went up to heaven
jesus gave them the great commission
and they were so empty
of themselves
that
they didn't care about what they had
their only concern
was
to please god
and to further his kingdom here on earth
today we have a problem
and the church of laodicea
is represented as a lukewarm church
now what does it mean that is lukewarm
well lukewarm is in between cold and hot
now what is it what does it mean to be
cold or what does it mean to be hot
there is not a single verse in the bible
that tells us
being hot is this
but there is a verse that tells us what
is like to be called jesus said in
matthew 24 because iniquity will abound
the love of many will wax cold
so call this lack of love
then the country would be
hot hot would be with much love
look warm is in between
i have a professional face
but
i do not have corresponding works
and i would say this is the main reason
why
we do not have that experience of the
early apostolic church of course we also
need to understand
that
times are different
even
things that were easier for them to do
in behalf of others today is not as easy
for example
back then if you wanted to adopt a child
it was easy but today you have to do a
lot of paperwork and i mean there are
certain things that
regulations
that hinder us from
freely helping our neighbor
but still
we can do
much today for for those who are in need
and and for those who are preaching the
word of god
i i think your answer is is balanced and
and and
well said um you will recall a few weeks
ago we were in a meeting together
and you were stressing a point uh and
you gave an
as an example
an example
uh the way it was done in colombia you
were familiar with that and then you
were made to realize the the
abundance of american regulations that
would not allow us to do it that way
yeah um
things are a little different now having
said that
um
churches should establish and many do
have
agencies to take care of
uh
those in need in the church
i remember the last church that i
pastored actually had a fund
that they collected to help with uh the
burial of church members who whose
families didn't have money for the
casket and the services and those kinds
of things so i think there is a
a aspect of collegiality uh that exists
in the church but the the fact is
there are many rules and regulations
that simply don't allow us to do some of
those things
that were done uh by the early church
now the truth be told whenever there is
a
a move of god in the church where the
church is energized and
and exercised over the the knowledge
that christ is coming soon there is this
feeling of collegiality where people are
not holding on to things or people are
not hoarding things where people are not
uh hanging on to things when uh the
millerite movement was in its heyday um
there were many people who were selling
their farms selling their lands giving
away things uh because they were
impressed with the idea that christ is
going to come soon correct so
those things did not matter and whenever
that spirit uh
reasserts itself in the church there is
this collegiality but
the truth is we we have settled down
into a sort of laodiceanism
that sort of marks everything that chur
that the church does
but
praise the lord
as we get closer to the end of time
laodiceanism is going to be
replaced by the loud cry
and the latter reign and the church will
once again
really set itself for war and for battle
and i think the the the mode and the
methodologies that the church uses will
change
but uh the government has really put his
hand on a lot of things yes and and if
you if you if you sometimes you can't
even give things away without government
permission you know and if you do you
get sued or or or
otherwise taking the quarter or some
other kind of thing so we've got to be
very very careful how we do things and
the way we do things and the government
regulations that
we want we want to do
i remember when uh something happened in
panama this ministry came down and
brought 144 000 tracks to give away uh
and we had to work oh it was it was a
i want to say a devil of a time trying
to get those tracks into the country and
you know off the docks and through uh
adwana through customs you know that
kind of thing so there are a lot of
things that really sort of get in your
way when you're trying to do good that
should not stop us from the effort
though so i agree with your point very
much daniel that we we need to do all we
can to hold as much and then if we see
people around us particularly of the
household of faith amen that need help
we ought to be ready willing and able to
to help them yes and also we need to be
careful about
fanatical movements and enthusiasm
some people get pumped up
by some energetic and fiery preacher
when presents a certain idea and people
just give up their things yes but then
they realized it was just enthusiasm and
they they regret
doing it and i remember the the case of
anna phillips or anna rice yes when
supposedly you know she was a prophet of
god and jones presents her testimony to
the church and people even gave gold
watches and
and then when they realized
that she was a false prophet some of
them were asking for their watches back
so
you know some people have gotten
discouraged about giving because of
these false revival movements that we've
had in the past and we still have today
but i believe there is a true movement
coming up soon yes yes in the future
under the power of the latter rain
people won't care about what they have
but they will all give themselves to the
work yeah and and to finish to finish
the work and preach the three angels
messages yeah and and to
and we'll leave this in just a moment
that with there are multitudes of of
scammers you got to be very careful yes
with what you do what causes you support
you've got to listen because with the
technology has come an increased ability
for people to be tricked to be fooled to
be lied to good point to be conned uh so
you've got to be very very careful sadly
but that's the world in which we now
find ourselves we've got to be very very
careful and one more thing brother e.m
is that we can testify here from secrets
and seal
is that
that spirit hasn't died out completely
in our church
because secrets and seal is standing
today first by god's grace and by your
help and your donations
so we have people out there
that are sharing of what they have and
because of their love offerings
secrets and seal exists yes so um there
are people out there and we're really
thankful for those who support our
ministries because they are following
the example
of
those sincere believers of the apostolic
church very true this ministry certainly
could not exist without people sharing
what god has blessed them with amen with
us and of course we are very very
thankful for that
all righty what do we have
next
is it agave
[Music]
de
and this one is on
this question is on solomon's temple i
am looking for
a
a city or perhaps a country and i don't
see one let me encourage you and this is
not this is not prerequisite but it
would be good to know where you are
writing us from uh it lets us know what
the the footprint of the ministry is and
gives us a sense of what's happening in
the world in the world church
in the world community
we've gotten
communications from all across the world
but if it's not too much of a bother
just add where you're writing from and
it doesn't have to be that street
address
but the city or the country and that
will be fine and then we can know uh
where the uh
person is running from this is agbeve
delali i doubt if this is from iowa
uh though it may be
i think this is probably outside of the
country but it would be good to know all
right please
what is the significance of not making
the laver
one lampstand one
and table one as it was oh one as it was
in the first tabernacle of moses but
instead ten in all and of course they
refer to second chronicles chapter four
verse six
he was also me he also made ten lavers
and put five on the right and five on
the left to wash in them such things as
they offered for burnt offering that
would they would wash them but the sea
was for the priest to wash it the sea
does not mean the cc of course it's the
big bowl the big bowl is used for water
um
he made 10 lamb stands of gold according
to the design and set them in the temple
five on the right side and five on the
left and verse eight he made also ten
tables and placed them in the temple
five on the right five on the left and
made one hundred bowls of gold yeah
well the the simple reason for this is
because solomon's temple or god's temple
built by solomon
was much larger than the former one
so the people had the population had
grown they needed more priests to
perform sacrifices one priest was not
enough so they needed more space
for that they needed more
furniture yes in order to do their work
more efficiently and to minister to the
needs of all the people so that's the
basic reason yes why
they were they instead of one they had
10 labors 10
tables of showbread and 10
candlesticks yes yes yeah this is a
problem
any pastor would love to have
we're getting too big yes
we're growing and we've got to
accommodate uh the increased demand
it is a problem uh that i can say obitum
that we are having praise the lord the
lord is asking us to move because we
have outgrown this lovely building
which uh we have been in for about 10
years but we are bursting at the seams
uh you and i share an office and uh with
a third person and then right next to us
is an office inhabited by five people
yes your wife works in a part of the
building that has one two three four and
twice a week five people in it so we are
simply getting a little big and we've
gotta look for bigger questions so it's
not it's not a very eclectic or esoteric
answer simply they were growing exactly
they had to accommodate the growth
that's right
very good
alrighty we are moving along i see our
time we've got a little time left
now this is what i like i'm from kenya
east africa is that lady that you have
lottie
okay larry i am from kenya east africa
i've been to canada east africa
church is doing very well growing very
very well there
i've recently come across some brethren
in the church
theologians especially who hold the view
that the spirit of prophecy represents
only the messages that reveal or talk
about jesus
and that in the writings of ellen and
that in the writings of ellen g white
e.g white the spirit of prophecy only
represents what she wrote and revealed
about jesus and that the private letters
written to individual persons or the
health messages or such writings in her
works do not constitute the spirit of
prophecy
is this the new adventist understanding
what does the term spirit of prophecy
mean
as used in the bible looking forward to
your spot response be blessed okay
oh we've got to go to revelation yeah
and uh 19
and 10 and and look at that designation
of the spiritual i i know
the mindset that produced this question
yes so we need to need to walk our way
walk our way through it
and actually uh
pastor um i've heard this before
that if it wasn't printed in a book
it wasn't published by the illinois
estate it's not spirit of prophecy so
that personal counsel
uh doesn't count um
and and that's a problematic right and i
have a quote for that here even from her
own pen
uh where she answers that but let's like
the biblical foundation as you were
saying
uh revelation 19 10 you said
you want me to read it please all right
so you cross reference this with
revelation 12 17 where it says that the
remnant church will have the testimony
of jesus christ
and here we find
this following verse and it says and i
fell at his feet to worship him but he
said to me see that thou do not do that
i am your fellow servant and you're one
of your brethren
who have the testimony of jesus worship
god for the testimony of jesus is the
spirit of prophecy so it says here that
he is a fellow servant the angel of your
brethren and this brethren john's
brethren
have the testimony of jesus and the
testimony of jesus is the spirit of
prophecy now
you know revelation 22 verse 9 tells us
who john's brethren are yes it says that
john's brethren are the prophets the
prophets it says here i am your fellow
servant and of your brethren the prophet
so
that that
the spirit of prophecy
is a a phrase or let me see a
description
that is applied to
all the prophets those who have
the gift of prophecy
and now it is true
that all the prophets have jesus as
their center
jesus is the center of every prophecy
but that doesn't mean that only what
ellen white spoke about jesus
and i would say that these are of ages
thoughts from the amount of blessing
christ object lessons
steps to christ
those are the only inspired books yes
because her vision uh there there is a
common theme a motif that runs through
all the writings of ellen white and is
the great conflict
or the great controversy motif yes
with jesus as the sinner you know
patriarchs and prophets begins with god
is love
and the great controversy ends with god
is love love correct so in between there
is this question about whether god is
love or not
and ellen white develops that which is
actually
what the bible talks about from the
beginning to the end
god
showing that he is love so
uh i i believe is a very limited idea to
say
that only the messages that reveal or
talk about jesus are the only inspired
messages i believe
this is a very skewed and limited idea
this lowers
the authority authority of ellen white
then would have to discard the great
controversy
we would have to discard all her
scathological perspective of end times
and all the councils that she wrote on
other subjects like health yeah like
education
like family and all those things because
if you know if it is only about the love
of jesus then she's just a devotional
writer
you know it's um i'll give you an
example and i love your your response
daniel um
you were saying then just because it
wasn't on jesus it wasn't the spire of
the lord
that that really makes no sense that
that is i'm gonna use this term i use it
prayerfully
it is a constipated view yeah of the
spirit of prophecy
um
for instance
ellen white had a dream she saw a man in
the dream
and she mentioned to some people
you know i saw this man in my dream and
since he stood out in my dream
i will probably see him again
and there's some people there that she
talked to
six weeks seven weeks later
she was in a meeting and there the man
sat she said you know i saw you
in in my dream
she said you were in chicago you're at a
meeting
and you did something
with another woman
that that i saw
i saw
who the person was and i saw you
and she chose at that point to call him
out in public and i i don't know why
but she did
he admitted yes
i've never done it before
and
i committed to god that i would never do
it again
and she said yeah that's what the lord
the lord told me
that it was the first time and it would
be your last but that you must keep
guard because this is a temptation that
will come to you again
now was that inspired by the lord or not
of course of course it was of course it
was the whole incident wasn't exactly
god she saw him in a dream provided by
god she saw the incident provided by god
she saw the who provided by god she knew
she would be seeing them again so uh
none of this made it into a published
book it got into a manuscript and and
and i happened to run across it but
that is much the moving of the holy
spirit god telling her god informing her
god instructing her as anything written
in the desire of ages or in those books
so there's much counsel uh all of the
counsel she gave to to john harley
kellogg in letters exactly you know many
many things yeah that were inspired by
god so you cannot just limit the light
to those things that happen that were
printed in the book i i had to when i
took a class the life and writings of l
g white i had to write a paper on
the inspiration for helen white so the
person is interested just
send us an email and i will be willing
to share my paper with you
about how inspired was ellen white
and
what do we do when it comes to her
letters
and before i go to one of her quotes
you know if we discard letters as not
inspired then we need to discard most of
paul's epistles
because those are letters there are
letters that he sent to churches or
individuals like timothy titus
and we would say well that was just a
common thing that
you know some situation with titles or
timothy but those letters are in the
bible because
we have instruction in those letters yes
originally they were written to timothy
or titles but they have instruction for
us as well so same with ellen white's
letters very true she says here this is
selected messages book 2
page 27
i wrote many pages to be read at your
camp meeting
weak and trembling i arose at three
o'clock in the morning to write you
god was speaking through clay so she's
the claim
you might say that these
communication was only a letter yes it
was a letter but prompted by the spirit
of god yeah to bring before your minds
things that had been shown me
in these letters which i write
in the testimonies i bear
i am presenting to you that which the
lord has presented to me
i do not write one article in the paper
expressing merely my own ideas
they are what god has opened before me
in vision the precious rays of light
shining from the throne and that's a
solemn statement it is now one more
point
we do not mean to say
with this
and i hope i i'm not misunderstood
with what i'm going to say
that
everything
she wrote
is equally inspired
and i'm going to i'm going to define
that
because she makes a difference between
what she calls sacred writings
and common writings
thankfully we have from her own pen
what she considers not inspired and only
those portions are not inspired she says
here and i have only a few seconds i'm
going to read it real quick but there
are times when common things must be
stated common thoughts must occupy the
mind common letters must be written and
information given that has passed from
one to another
of the workers such words such
information are not given and they're
under the special inspiration of the
spirit of god questions are acts asked
at times
not upon religious subjects at all
for example questions about lands trades
to be made locations for our
institutions advantages and
disadvantages so
there are lots of questions on this but
uh thank you for sending your questions
with us god bless you see you next time
[Music]
you